oh where do i want to go american gps
revolutionized navigation and it's
everywhere but what if we didn't need it
two new satellite navigation systems
together leo and eggnos are set to take
europe boldly where it's never gone
before after mep's approved plans for
funding developed in joint collaboration
with the european space agency it's a
civilian run project promising better
service and gps great applications to
benefit the industry and the big brash
pledge no more foreign tech be it
american russian or chinese
it will be a very good project for for
europe
because first of all we shall not be
dependent anymore
of
gps american system which is a military
one during the war in iraq in 90 the gps
was interrupted because was used only
for military
will not be the case with galileo but
can galileo really deliver
we are making the whole galileo system
totally interoperable with gps which
makes sense but also not really able to
fully operate without gps we are still
dependent and we really delivered
galileo
on time and on budget it would have been
a good project we are late significantly
over budget
will it really make a difference for
europe seven percent of our gdp some 800
billion euros depends on gps under
galileo the eu could generate almost 69
billion euros a huge boost the economy
and jobs but some are skeptical now we
came to this game fine okay we also have
it but we are coming late i would much
prefer that we jump ahead of others in
other domains this is where europe's
competitive advantage lies meps are
expected to confirm the galileo budget
at the plenary in october